let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
good wednesday afternoon everybody
[Music]
welcome to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome we have
all kinds of stuff to talk about today
so let's talk
let's talk
[Music]
we have let's see what do we have today
what what is going on that what could
possibly be going on today that we could
talk about
um well we have uh speaker pelosi
uh totally slam dunking jim jordan and
jim banks into the [ __ ] trash can
and kevin mccarthy pitching a fit over
it we have that
uh we have rand paul getting slam dunked
by dr anthony fauci there's a lot of
slam dunking going on here
in the last few days uh even yesterday
marjory taylor green
couldn't figure out what hipaa actually
is so there's another there's another
case of a boneheaded republican
and uh we have jeff bezos
jeff bezos launched launched
his space dildo his dildo rocket
into space this thing looks like it
looks like a dick
i mean did you guys think it looked i
mean it
come on they had the mushroom head on it
who who punked this [ __ ]
thinking yeah this is a great design
no it'll be a great design it'll be a
great design of a rocket to make it look
like a hitachi vibrator
that's exactly what we should do and
then
a story i definitely want to get to i do
not want to waste any time
uh um getting to this story but we will
get to it
there's so much stuff going on uh tom
barrack
the head money launderer of the trump
inauguration committee back in 2017
the head launderer gets arrested by the
feds
gets arrested by the feds for nothing
other than you know
lobbying foreign actors foreign
countries
and not disclosing it you know trying to
get money from them
for certain people probably i don't know
we'll discover
what that is i'm sure i'm sure it has
nothing to do
nothing absolutely nothing to do with a
former guy i'm sure
and i would almost bet that tom
barrack is just a [ __ ] coffee boy
that trump has taken pictures with
before
sometime or not you know he takes
pictures with a lot of people a lot of
people
this person cannot be that important who
the hell is tom barrack anyways who
is he i don't know him do you know him i
don't know him i just took a picture
with the guy
so we'll get into that so we got a lot
of stuff to talk about today
a hell of a lot of stuff to talk about
today but i do want to start
with the jeff bezos things get that out
of the way um because there was a few
more things other than his rocket
looking like a
like a damn vibrator um that i want to
get to
some of the things that he said after he
got
off his dildo rocket uh and into space
because uh as cool as it is
that a billionaire would launch
themselves in the space
coming back and not paying taxes is kind
of a downfall to it but
we should keep them in space unless
they're going to pay a tax to get back
in maybe that's what we should do
we should create a tax you know us
liberals we like to create taxes
right we're all back taxing oppression
of taxes
so what we should do hear me out here
what we should do is create a tax
to make sure that if a billionaire
leaves the earth's orbit
that we charge them i don't know i don't
know how much money
maybe maybe half of their assets to come
back in
i mean jesus they they got enough money
anyways right so
but jeff bezos goes up in the space in
his in his
in his hitachi by his oversized attachy
hot vibrator
he comes back down he's all excited he
looks like dr evil
right i mean this guy's got the shaved
head and he comes
back down
and he gets in front of a microphone and
the the the thing that this guy does is
he
thanks his underpaid employees
and his customers for making it all
possible holy [ __ ]
can you imagine being a [ __ ] amazon
employee and
hearing after the guy who owns who owns
your company and who pays you pitens to
do the work that you do
shoots himself into a into space in a
[ __ ] dildo
comes back into space's orbit lands on
earth
stands out in front of a microphone and
says thank you so much
for working for pennies that way i can
afford to go into space
wow look enough of the thank yous
enough of the thank yous just pay your
[ __ ] employees a decent [ __ ] wage
pay him a decent [ __ ] wage advocate
for your tax rate to be higher
and and stop [ __ ] you know showing
off because we could do all these things
he could go into space in a oversized
vibrator
he could pay his employees more he could
be taxed
five times as much 10 times as much and
still have enough money
afterwards okay so let's
stop arguing about this stuff but it is
really nice of him
that he thanked his employees and us
customers of amazon
it's so nice that he thanked us for his
ride
in his attach oversized hitachi vibrator
so um here is the tweet i sent
because it was really weird yesterday um
because uh this tom barrack story hit
and when when you went to trending on
twitter
rand paul is at the top which we're
gonna talk about that story
rand paul is at the very top for getting
his
ass handed to him by dr anthony fauci he
got the out voucher ouchie
in the committee hearing like out loud
the verbal
fouchy ouchy is what he got
and that's it so rand paul's trending
number one
jeff bezos is trending number two
how is that even possible how do we have
how do we have jeff bezos going into
space a billionaire going into space
in a dick-shaped rocket and that's not
trending number one
we're we're this [ __ ] is is backwards in
this universe people
and then and then the tom barrack story
hits
the trump ally the head money launderer
or the inauguration committee
gets arrested by the feds
and he's going to spend the whole
weekend in jail because they're not
going to do his arraignment until monday
which is kind of odd we'll talk about
that
but he he he's not trending number one
what i what i questioned was was
has anyone seen rudy giuliani holy [ __ ]
where's rudy
because that could be significant
so let's get to this tom
barrack story some people say barack
some people say barrick
um again i think he's the head money
launderer
of the trump inauguration campaign i
think that's probably i mean
you know it seems like that's what this
could be about
if you look at this i mean he he's he's
being charged with foreign
lobbying uh and not disclosing he was
foreign lobbying
with the uae right um
trump had projects there he had projects
in saudi arabia this is the first trip
that the former guy [ __ ] took the
first foreign trip not to canada not to
mexico not to one of our other allies
he goes to saudi arabia do you remember
the orb
picture where he's standing and he's
grabbing the orb
and it looked like you know the evil
villains
from a [ __ ] comic standing around the
orb you know
doing their thing [ __ ] weird
this is [ __ ] weird it was [ __ ]
weird
but he goes and pals around over in
saudi arabia
the same time the same time about the
same time
you know that same year that same time
period that
tom barrack his head money launder of
the inauguration campaign
uh was lobbing the uae which ivanka
ivanka and trump have been lobbying the
uae and saudi arabia for years to have
projects there and to honor money
through their real estate allegedly
i mean who doesn't know that that's what
the trump organization is about by now
i mean this all seems convenient
doesn't it it seems a little [ __ ]
convenient
that we have we have alan weiselberg
under indictment and the manhattan d.a
in new york
we have the one of the guys who was
donating a ton of money
a ton of money a ton of money
to the trump inaugural campaign he was
foreign lobbying
he was lobbying the uae at the same time
the same time that he's working on the
inaugural
committee alan weisselberg
and ivanka trump now
the last few weeks we've seen roger
stone not be
so friendly with ivanka trump and jared
kushner
on social media and all of a sudden
all of a sudden we have now a connection
between ivanka and jared and the
inaugural committee and alan weiselberg
we have tom barrack who is arrested by
the feds
on foreign lobbying charges the other
thing about this
that is very telling very telling
is that he is going to spend the entire
weekend in lock-up
and detainment and the reason why is he
has to wait for his arraignment
see when you get indicted you have to go
before a judge
and they have to arraign you they have
to officially tell you hey you're
[ __ ] indicted
and then they have to set your bail
sometimes they let you lose
sometimes just under your free will
sometimes they give you an ankle
bracelet and sometimes they're like
sorry [ __ ] you're in jail and we've
seen that we've seen that and you know
you know how this can work um because
we've seen this with the
insurrectionists these 500 people some
of them they've let loose
some of them they've let loose with an
ankle bracelet on home confinement home
detainment
and some of them they've detained in in
federal custody a lot of times it's in
the federal courthouse
it depends on where it's at but there's
a they're in federal detention
right and really they're under federal
detention
rather they're out and about or not
because they're under federal indictment
i mean there's certain
conditions when they enter their plea
which
all indications are is that tom barrack
is going to enter a not guilty plea
but the funny thing is the funny thing
is is they arrested him
in l.a and sent him back to new york
now the reason why that might be
significant and that might be why
they're waiting for the arraignment
because
normally when you you are arrested or
you turn yourself
in that's normally you know on a case
like this they normally let you self
surrender
sometimes unless they're pressuring you
you know maybe a little bit of pressure
maybe trying to figure out some things
and they arrest you at
a in a completely different place
and take you all the way across the
country and make you sit entertainment
in a cell for the entire weekend
to really think about things you know
really really
get into the mindset of what's about to
happen to you before you're arraigned by
a federal judge so
that seems kind of convenient that he
would be entertainment to where
you know the prosecutors the court
would know exactly where he's at now he
has a right to an attorney just like any
other american out there
or anyone in the american justice system
his color okay he's a white guy his
color you have the right
yeah you know it's a little shaky in our
justice system but you know
that's the way it's supposed to be not
always that way you know
but he has a right to an attorney but
they know exactly where he is
they know exactly what he's doing they
know exactly how much pressure is being
put on him
the funny part is about the whole thing
and i think it's kind of odd that uh
allen weisselberg was on the inaugural
committee he's indicted
in a manhattan in a manhattan
district by the manhattan da in the
state of new york he's indicted
for tax and money things right
and tom barrack
he was on the inaugural committee and
he's being indicted
not for the inaugural committee but he
had something to do with it and this
foreign lobbying
kind of bleeds into the inaugural thing
kind of bleeds into that stuff you know
when this all this
crying goes around all these
criming stains start to kind of cross
over a little bit
and you have roger stone completely
completely abandoning jared kushner and
ivanka trump which ivanka trump was on
the inaugural committee
and she was there with alan weisselberg
helping
ooh helping set up the inaugural
committee which raised over 100 million
dollars and poof
some of it disappeared we're still
wondering where the hell some of that
money went hmm
or where it came from really where it
came from
i don't know maybe just maybe if we had
some kind of corrupt president elected
you know i'm not talking about anyone
specific here
maybe if we had a corrupt president uh
elected
and he wanted certain projects done in
the middle east you know like maybe
saudi arabia or uae
and he had a friend i'm not saying who
that friend
could be or would be maybe they're
really rich
right maybe they're really rich and they
have a lot of influence in
countries like saudi arabia or the uae
kind of in that area in that vicinity
where they're wanting to open up hotels
and golf courses right
and you're gonna say well we're gonna
have an opportunity
here to raise a bunch of money for a big
old party
and the nice part is is no one will know
what we spend
right and no one will see the money just
go
poof go away so maybe just maybe
we should consider where we get the
money and how
we steal the money if it that is a
completely
if if we had a corrupt person that was
elected
i mean this is all this is all
hypothetical folks there's no way
no way that this country could fall for
that right
i'm just hypothetically speaking here
so tom barrack is going to be arraigned
on monday um and maybe we'll know
more and maybe when the
when the judge sets his bail and find
out are they going to lock him up are
they going to let him lose
you know what what is it that they're
going to do how he's going to plea maybe
he please guilty
seriously doubt it but maybe he does
maybe he does
but it sounds like it sounds like people
connected to trump
and people connected to the trump
inaugural committee
and the inauguration and how they raised
the funds it sounds
like it sounds like the feds are really
looking into that
and there's a guy in new york named alan
weisselberg that has something to do
with it also
a lady with the last name trump that
might have something to do with it
so we need to probably be paying
attention to anything that has to do
with
that so i'll rest my case
there and let's let's move on down the
list of things we want to talk about
because we do have a ton of [ __ ] to get
to today
um it is not just uh this barack which
here's the here's the tweet
here's the official ap report uh of the
breaking news
that uh uh the the uh the head of the
inaugural committee
uh tom barrack was arrested so there it
is i'm not
lying that's the ap report um
you know it's not fake news he's sitting
in a jail cell all weekend
so good luck to him so we have we have
some more
uh news uh on the hill
uh yesterday there was a committee
hearing with anthony fauci as a witness
uh of course uh the [ __ ] bag senator
rand paul
was questioning anthony fauci and this
is always interesting
this is always interesting uh when you
watch rand paul uh
question anthony fauci because anthony
fauci just rolls him up and flicks him
like a
like a a really a really really really
sticky booger
it's fantastic it's fantastic to watch
this happen
and a lot of people were kind of pissed
off about this but
uh rand paul basically accuses anthony
fauci of committing perjury
uh before congress he accuses him of of
of crime he accuses him of lying in
front of congress under oath
perjury well
what a lot of people don't understand is
anthony fauci
cannot commit perjury in front of
congress now he cannot lie
now what i mean by that is i don't mean
that anthony fauci
physically or mentally can't lie that's
not what i mean
what i mean is is anthony fauci cannot
lie in front of congress without the
possibility of consequences
that's how that works now on the other
side of that
coin mr rand paul he
absolutely absolutely can lie
in a congressional committee hearing
there's nothing
binding him there's no consequence well
i mean other than
you know maybe his neighbor
opens up a can of of of voting
he's we need to get his neighbor
involved in this
because we want his neighbor to you know
vote against rand paul that's what i'll
say we want him to vote
however is possible i mean aggressively
aggressively
vote against rand paul is really what we
want his neighbor to do
but back to the committee hearing rand
paul
absolutely other than being ejected from
congress which they probably would not
do because these [ __ ] bags lie
all the time in committee hearings they
do it all the time
because they're not bound by oath the
people
questioning the people under oath are
not bound by oath maybe we should do
that
maybe we should make it to where the
people
asking the questions have to be under
oath they
certainly can lie there's nothing
stopping them for perpetuating a lying
outright lying and anthony fauci slam
dunked that [ __ ]
like i said he rolled him up and flicked
him like a sticky booger
he totally obliterated him and basically
said
you're accusing me of lying
by stating a lie and propagating lies
which he is and i'm not gonna get into
the whole
uh the whole thing of why anyone was
lying or someone wasn't
all you have to know is know that rand
paul
is a piece of [ __ ] garbage and
he absolutely will lie about anything
that he wants to and has to
to advance what he sees as his political
career
i mean this guy wants to be on fox news
at night
you know the reason why a lot of
professional basketball players
want to slam dunk the ball you know they
really want to get a good [ __ ] dunkin
is to get the highlights on espn that's
one of the reasons
you get a home run you want to get on a
highlight you catch a huge
hail mary touchdown pass or throw a huge
hail mary touchdown pass
you'll want to be on the [ __ ]
highlights
well rand paul loves to be in the
highlights
he loves it he loves it the same way as
ted cruz and some of these other [ __ ]
bags love it
they want to be in the highlights on fox
news
oan and newsmax that's their that's
their goal
that's the whole point so
rand paul did what he did yesterday
being the [ __ ] bag that he is and
accused anthony fauci of lying
and and if you go watch the the the clip
uh anthony fauci again rolls him up
and flicks him like a sticky booger it
is fantastic
and and of course of course you know
when you watch the
when a right winger watches the clip
someone who's against dance and anthony
fauci and thinks that anthony fauci
did all this to us it can't be trump's
fault it has to be anthony
it has to be anthony fauci only one
person
only one person is responsible for the
coronavirus only one
well that's not true that's not true
but they want they they see the clip and
they think
rand paul slam dunk anthony fauci but
what they don't realize
what they don't realize is anthony fauci
is the one under oath
not rand paul so rand paul has no
ramifications for just spewing a bunch
of garbage he has no ramifications at
all none
i mean other than me sitting here
talking about him or anyone else talking
about him and calling him a liar and
anthony fauci calling him a liar on the
official record
and anthony fauci basically made it part
of the official record that he was a
[ __ ] lying sack of [ __ ] which
it really doesn't have to be on the
official record to know
that rand paul is a lying sack of [ __ ]
so i'll leave it there now
we just have a whole list of [ __ ] bags
to get to today i don't know how else to
to say it i don't know how to to frame
it up
we got a whole list of them today so put
your hats on folks
put your hats on let's see we got some
uh we got some comments maybe i can get
to those
a lot of people like the uh like the
dildo rocket thing i
i think it looked like a hitachi
vibrator that's what i think it looked
like
i mean it had the head on it and i mean
i've never actually used one
maybe i should but i've never actually
used one but i've
seen them i've seen them and you know i
i've been in a dildo store before who
hasn't been in a porn shop before
and if you haven't been you know maybe
maybe just maybe you're like the next
person i'm going to talk about which is
marjorie taylor green
and you would never divulge that you've
been in a dildo shop because
it would be against your hipaa rights
so marjorie taylor green is being
questioned by reporters you guys have
seen this clip
you've seen this clip you've seen this
clip and and this is this is what we get
from um from these uh right-wing morons
all the time when you're asking them uh
a question about
a certain type of passport right of
and and and of course they they get it
completely confused and wrong
um she's asked she's asked by a reporter
if she's well first off steve scalise
received the vaccine steve scalise
received the vaccine several days
ago that's what the reporter the story
that the reporter was referring to
and representative scalise gave the
reason why
he was going to be vaccinated was
because the delta variant was running
around it's a big risk
and the risk outweighs a reward to get
the shot
right that's that's what steve scalise
said
in basic terms now
marjorie taylor green was being asked
and she's they said hey
did you hear that steve scalise got the
vaccine
are you vaccinated is what they asked
that's what they asked
are you vaccinated she gets pissed
you are violating my hipaa rights
you're breaking the law which that's not
what hyporites are
that's not even close i mean you're not
even the same
universe of what of what hipaa laws are
hipaa hipaa refers to your medical
records when it has to do
with the doctors or the hospital like
literally
i mean in a nutshell hipaa
hipaa is where the doctor
has to have your permission to release
your medical records to anyone
even you even you
even yourself like if you went in and
you wanted your medical records
from your doctor and you said hey doc i
want my medical records and i want them
now
the hell with those hipaa laws the
doctors say nope sorry
you have to sign this form giving me
permission to give it to you
what i'm telling you i'm saying right
now they're mine i want them
he's not gonna give a [ __ ] she's not
gonna give a [ __ ] they're not gonna give
a [ __ ]
don't care if you
need your medical records from your
doctor they need your [ __ ] permission
to give them to you
that's what hipaa is it has nothing to
do with asking someone
what stage of cancer that they have
or if they if the reason why they took
tylenol yesterday was because they had a
mild headache
that has nothing to do with hipaa and by
the way
this is why these people get the first
and second amendment wrong all the time
this is why they get it wrong they have
no [ __ ] clue what they're talking
about
they don't know what the first amendment
is they have no clue what the second
amendment says
they can't even figure out what who who
is
applicable to hipaa
this is why they always get it wrong
they have no [ __ ] clue they always
pull the [ __ ] straight out of their ass
make it up as they go along it sounds
great
it sounds great on facebook makes a good
facebook meme
so let's say it let's say that you're
just breaking my hipaa rights which
it applies to medical professionals to
your specific
medical records and releasing those
medical records to somebody
even yourself and if you've ever ever
bought an insurance policy
life insurance health insurance if you
ever
had a job that needed your medical
records which your job
can require medical records they can
require that
that's that's how this country works
it's called
capitalism freedom they can require your
medical records
but if your company the company that
you're gonna go work for
requires that you give them your medical
records
you have to sign a hipaa form giving the
doctor
the permission to give your company your
[ __ ] medical
records that's hipaa that's hipaa
now if your company says hey
how you feeling today you look you look
a little
tired the hr person ask you hey you look
a little tired today
are you worn out you're breaking my
hipaa rights that's not hyporites
that's not what the [ __ ] that is that's
not hyporites and besides
you have the first amendment if you knew
what the [ __ ] the first amendment said
you would know that you
don't have to tell anyone anything i
mean if you're accused of murder
and you got three four five six police
officers staring you down because you're
accused of murder do you know
do you know how many things you have to
tell them not one [ __ ] thing
not a [ __ ] thing you can tell them to
[ __ ] off
you can say lawyer lawyer lawyer lawyer
lawyer
lawyer lawyer actually it's the fifth
amendment
sorry right to remain silent but your
first amendment
you had the right to also not say
something
see i even get him confused it's a
little hairy
the hippolaws are a little hairy too
marjorie taylor green
and then she laughed she laughed at a
child dying
um you gotta go watch that clip too but
i'm not even gonna get into that because
we have to get to
the main story today which is gonna take
up most the time here
i believe this is to take up most the
time and we're at about 30 minutes so
we're about halfway through here
we're about halfway through but we got
we got to get to
we got to get to the january 6
select committee this is the big story
coming out of washington
right now uh of course you know weeks
and weeks and weeks ago
uh the democrats and some republicans in
the house
tried to get a 911 style commission
that's what they tried to do
and they got it through the house went
to the senate and
they couldn't get a 911 style
commission together for january 6.
now obviously january 6 is being
investigated on several different levels
the same way that 911 was
uh kevin mccarthy does not understand
that he he got it all botched up
today uh when he gave his press
conference and we'll talk about that
here in a second but he basically
will talk about what he did ultimately
with the appointments that he made
but he he botched it he said oh the 911
commission
uh nancy pelosi went outside the scope
of it because
she doesn't want to talk about the
things that led up to it which he's
talking about black lives matter in
antifa
that's what they're talking about what
they want to do
inside of a select committee is blame is
blame
all all the protest all the protests
that happened
last summer in 2020 because of the death
of george floyd they want to make that
part of the january 6th commission
they want to conflate those two things
which those two things are not
conflatable
they're not related they're not
and they they got all [ __ ] up when
when black lives matter in antifa in
particular didn't end up being any of
the people being arrested
for the january january 6 insurrection
i mean if there would have been a couple
dozen of these antifa
antifa you know anti-fascist people who
don't like
fascism that's why fascists hate antifa
that's why antifa is their enemy
fascist hate antifa it's a natural thing
when you're you're when you're a [ __ ]
nazi you don't like antifa that's how it
works
like they're your natural enemy not an
ally
so they want to blame it on antifa they
want to blame it on black lives matter
but it has nothing to do with the
protest that happened last summer now
they want to say it did
and the reason why they want to say that
it has to do with the protest last
summer
the black lives matter protest when
george floyd was murdered by derrick
chauvin
the reason why they want to conflate
those two things is because they really
do believe and they're out in the open
that it's about white grievance
that's that's what it is it's about
january 6 was 100 full stop
about white grievance it's about a bunch
of snowflake
white supremacist white people in this
country
scared terrified terrified
that if people get equality then we
won't we'll be oppressed
that's that's what it's about it's all
white grievance
trump is white grievance grievance
q anon is white supremacist grievance
it's grievance
white supremacist grievance all of it
and that's why that's why they didn't
want a 911 style
commission is because they really
couldn't stir the pot
if they really had a non-biased
commission giving a report
on january 6 like 911 gave on the
september 11th attacks
in new york on the world trade center
and in pennsylvania and at the pentagon
if they really had a non-biased
bipartisan
commission that gave a report on that
they would be completely [ __ ]
completely [ __ ] so that's why they
squashed that
because that wasn't in their best
interest their best interest was is to
make it all political
the whole thing make the commission
political again
and that is the difference kevin
mccarthy
in a 911 style commission and now
is because during 9 11 during september
11th when we were attacked by terrorists
in this country republicans democrats
independents everyone kind of looked at
each other and said
you know what we should probably
investigate these terrorists
the difference now the difference now
is that we're kind of playing around
this idea of letting the terrorists
investigate themselves
you're the [ __ ] terrorist your party
your white grievance party
part of domestic terrorism and you're
perpetuating it
you're perpetuating it every day every
time you open your mouth
to you know every time you put on your
cheeto dust knee pads
every time you service the orange deity
every single [ __ ] time
every time you pretend that he [ __ ]
won
every time that you pretend that he's
still the president
every time you play with the idea that
he's gonna come back as president in
august
you are perpetuating domestic terrorism
that's what you're doing
you you so that is the difference
kevin mccarthy between 9 11
and january 6 and those two events as
far as
us creating a committee or a commission
to investigate it
is back on 9 11 we would not have let
osama bin laden
jim jordan osama bin laden sorry today
kind of got a thing in my throat there
we would not allow jim
osama bin laden jordan i mean uh osama
bin laden
be on the 911
commission we would not have done that
no one would have thought oh that's a
great idea
let the terrorists investigate
themselves i actually i actually did a
video about this a while back
when when the
the commission was going through the
senate and mitch mcconnell was doing
everything he could to stop it so was
kevin mccarthy really
honestly i did a little video about it
it's called potato tomato right tourism
terrorism it's the same thing they were
just tourists
you know because their antifa thing fell
and then the whole thing where it's
nancy pelosi's fault that fell apart
now they're now they're on the tourist
thing these people aren't bad people
are patriots yeah well patriots don't
try to overthrow the government of the
united states
that's not what happens it's not what
happens insurrectionists do
seditious treasonous pieces of [ __ ] do
that
so let me play you the ditty that i have
uh on the january
six uh commission and
the same applies to this select
committee because this is the other
option
and we'll talk more about what happened
today with nancy pelosi
and the five republicans that were
appointed by kevin mccarthy
after the video on the other side
tourism terrorism
potato tomato let's talk big traders
kevin mccarthy and moscow mitch
mcconnell
do not want to commission looking into
the january 6th treasonous insurrection
hmm i wonder why it be that them and
some of their members were trying to
overthrow the government of the united
states
yeah no [ __ ] sherlock they're going to
let the seditious traders vote on
whether we should investigate them or
not jesus
[ __ ] christ don't like this 911 style
commission [ __ ]
that's because they're the [ __ ]
terrorists just think about it wouldn't
been [ __ ] swell if the 911 terrorists
got to vote not to be
investigated jesus would have been even
better if they would have had a
propaganda cable news show
called schmucker carlson or some [ __ ]
like that
how to spread the fear and their
terrorist lies around believe your eyes
it was just a regular plane ride on a
tour
of the world trade centers connor
mccarthy and all you treason is manga
trump bumpers in congress
go munch on a big bag of horse dicks
[ __ ] them
i mean if we can conjure up a big bag
uh i think the first people that should
step up to the buffet
what do you think what do you think what
do you think
put it in the comments there so
let me so nancy pelosi here's here's the
ap
article uh nancy pelosi the the speaker
of the house
declines and throws in the trash and
vetoes rejects
however you want to say it she slammed
dunks uh the two gems
the gems the jimmy gems jim jordan and
jim
banks uh obviously we
know why she slam dunked jim jordan uh
there's no
there's no [ __ ] secret of why jim
jordan
is not gonna be on this committee and
nancy pelosi is gonna make sure she's
not on the
make sure he's on the committee 100
percent
it's because jim jordan is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] show he's a [ __ ] show that's the
whole point of
kevin mccarthy appointing him in the
first place
is just make a mockery just make a [ __ ]
show out of it that's all that is
jim jordan that's all he is anyways it's
all show it's all show we heard eric
swalwell yesterday or the day before
talking on the midas touch podcast about
how these people think this is
professional wrestling
if you met ted cruz jim jordan
or or any of these other [ __ ] idiots
out in public you'd be like well that's
not the person i see
in committee hearings that's not the
person i see
on fox news that's because they're not
they're pretending it's all [ __ ] fake
it's all a [ __ ] show
and jim jordan jim jordan not having a
suit coat on is part of the [ __ ] show
jim i don't report sex crimes jordan
and kevin mccarthy knows this kevin
mccarthy knows
new past tense and because the the
reason why is because kevin mccarthy
when nancy pelosi rejected jim jordan
and jim banks
as two of his five appointments to the
january 6th select committee
kevin mccarthy tucked tails and run
takes his ball and goes home because
wha wham boo hoo they're snowflakes
they've always been the snowflakes
they're butt hurt butt hurt but the
other reason why
or the other person that we seen was jim
banks and the reason why is because jim
branks
has already been trying to raise money
off this he
posted incendiary comments about january
6 and how it you know
basically posting lies i mean that's
what these people do is they [ __ ] lie
that's how that's how their politics
works that's why they're
backed into a corner they painted
himself into this corner
for nancy pelosi to tell them to go [ __ ]
off
i'm not always a fan of nancy pelosi
but when i am it's because she's the
gqp's
kryptonite that's how i feel about it
but she tells them to go [ __ ] off
go take your ball and go home and it
sounds like
now i've been preparing for the podcast
so it's possible that she's already made
some announcements
i read her statement i render a
statement it sounds like she's gonna
make more appointments
now the media has been saying it's a
non-bipartisan commission without kevin
mccarthy giving appointments but that's
all [ __ ]
that's all [ __ ] we know liz cheney
was appointed by nancy pelosi
nancy pelosi who is not who is not a
political friend of
liz cheney by any means no i mean there
they probably disagree on 98 of [ __ ]
things
right i i i'm not even thrilled that liz
cheney's on the committee
i'm not a liz cheney fan at all never
have been
never [ __ ] will be now as long as
she's as long as she pretends to stand
up for democracy i'm good
she's not really for democracy but as
long as she pretends like it
it's good for us it's good for democracy
they've always been pretending to be
for democracy that's clear now that's
clear
but you know authoritarianism
totalitarianism it's tough to pretend
that you like democracy so liz cheney's
pretending she likes democracy so she's
on the committee
adam adam kinsinger well he can pretend
pretty well that he likes democracy too
so maybe maybe she'll appoint him on the
committee but she appointed liz cheney
with her original picks
what do you mean this isn't bipartisan
what do you mean there isn't a
conservative
on this select committee give me a
[ __ ] break nancy pelosi
picked a cheney a cheney
a cheney do you remember her dad
he was the vice president at one point
you know
a couple wars ones that
were now just ending 20 [ __ ] years
later come on
liz cheney is not a [ __ ] liberal
socialist commie
the [ __ ] out of here and if you think
that you are not on the same planet
and that may be the problem that may be
why you would
appoint a jim jordan or kevin mccarthy
appoints jim jordan
maybe he appoints jim jordan because he
knows
he knows nancy pelosi is going to veto
that [ __ ]
and slam dunk that nomination or that
appointment to that committee into the
[ __ ] trash
of course of course kevin mccarthy knows
that
how could you not know that everyone
knew that i tweeted about it when it
happened
when he nominated him i'm like yeah
she's gonna veto that [ __ ] 100
she's gonna tell him to go [ __ ] himself
and she did
she did she gave him the middle finger
that's enough you're not
on the committee sorry buddy you
shouldn't even be in congress let alone
on a select committee
you should have no committee
appointments is what you should have
or shouldn't have one or the other
but kevin mccarthy knew this kevin
mccarthy knew that nancy pelosi would
veto
jim i don't report sex crimes jordan
of course he knew that she would reject
that and that would give him permission
to pull all his not his his appointments
all five of them
that would give him the ability to pull
all five of them throw a little fit and
act like
9 11. oh it's different than now because
of nancy pelosi
no 9 11 is different than the january 6
because you're the terrorist
your supporters your party your party
leader
your president his allies they were the
domestic terrorists they
flew the planes into the buildings as it
were
you dumb [ __ ] now
it's hard to admit that i guess because
you want to remain the minority leader
so you have to put your cheeto dust knee
pads on to make sure you remain the
minority leader
and maybe one of these days maybe one of
these days you'll be the speaker of the
house which is not going to happen
kevin mccarthy 100 will never be the
speaker of the house he will never be
the speaker the house he will not be
100 right now speaking he is not
ever going to be the speaker of the
house he's already been down this road
and he got [ __ ]
trash then you remember he was on fox
news and he talked about another select
committee
the benghazi committee and he's talking
about how the republicans started the
benghazi committee to make sure that
hillary clinton couldn't get elected
he said it out loud on fox news and
because he's an idiot and he said that
out loud on fox news
they didn't make him they didn't make
him the speaker of the house which he
was
when john boehner retired he should have
been kevin mccarthy
should have been the likely candidate to
be the speaker of the house for the
republican majority but they he wasn't
because he's a [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
bonehead
that's why he's doing what he's doing
now because he's a [ __ ] bonehead
he's an idiot he's a [ __ ] idiot
and that's why they can lead him around
that's why they like him as a minority
leader
now as the speaker they can't have
someone dumb as a speaker because
nancy pelosi and the democrats will run
all up and down his ass
so they had to they had to force paul
ryan you remember paul ryan's like
nope nope don't want to be speaker nope
i'm not not going to do that [ __ ] that
don't want to do that that'll ruin my
political career guess what
where's paul ryan anyone heard from paul
ryan can you call fox news why don't you
call fox news
the uh the the board at fox news and see
where paul ryan's at
see if he's still the speaker of the
house
kevin mccarthy is a bonehead and never
will be the speaker of the house the
only reason why he's the minority leader
is because they can lead him around
he's their puppet but today today he
does exactly what he was told to do
just like he was told to do when he put
jim jordan on that
as an appointment on that committee
he was told hey put jim jordan on there
because nancy pelosi will definitely
veto him because he's a [ __ ] idiot
he's an idiot he'll say the word antifa
500 times
let's put him on there maybe a thousand
how many times
okay so jim jordan's not gonna be on the
select committee
but we should really take some bets on
how many
times jim jordan would have said the
word antifa
i mean what do you think you think it
meant five hundred maybe a thousand
i mean it could have been two thousand i
don't know antifa antiventipa that's
probably what they would keep saying
but he knew he knew nancy pelosi would
veto him
and that would give him the permission
the political permission you know
because this is all a [ __ ] show to
them
this is all professional wrestling like
eric swalwell said it's fake
it's fake ted cruz during the [ __ ]
impeachment trial told him in the
bathroom
hey you're doing a good job out there
buddy like what the [ __ ]
you just were on fox news saying i'm
some kind of commie [ __ ] bag
and you're congratulating me and the
[ __ ]
you're congratulating me and the [ __ ]
on the good work that i'm doing out
there when you're
on fox news saying i'm a traitor the
[ __ ] out of here ted cruz you fake ass
[ __ ]
this is all professional wrestling these
people all of it
all of it and trump is vince mcmahon
that's it trump is vince mcmahon they
have to live in his little [ __ ] fake
ass universe
it's all professional wrestling it's all
for the fans
and a lot of the fans a lot of the fans
know it's fake
but they're pretending that it's real i
talked about this with
[ __ ] anthony walker
hot medic if you're out there i talk to
you about this
about how these people think
in the way of a professional wrestling
fan they know this [ __ ] is fake
they know it's fake it's all [ __ ]
they just want to pretend it's fun to
pretend
the problem is the problem is we have a
certain percentage in this country and
it's a small percentage but it's a large
group of [ __ ] people
numbers wise who who believe this
garbage
they believe that it's real they believe
when ted cruz goes on fox news
and dunks on eric swalwell that he's
some kind of commie traitor
they believe it they believe him even
though ted cruz doesn't know it
or doesn't believe it and he knows it's
an act fox news knows it's an act
i mean jesus christ we've seen we've
seen sean hannity
sean hannity at fox news they're they're
all the same over there too
by the way it's all show over there
that's all that [ __ ]
network was all set up by roger ailes to
be the professional wrestling side of
the right wing
in this [ __ ] country all of it
that's what rogers ale's goal was was to
put on a show
so that way the sheep and the sheep out
there the right-wing sheep out there
could pretend that all this stuff was
real
see it's real it's on the news it's on
the news
see it's real it's real god at wrestling
it's on tv
it's on pete no it's all staged all of
it that's why kevin mccarthy picked jim
jordan
so he he could retract all five
appointments because now what has to
happen
is either they have to go with the
quorum that they have because they have
a quorum they can continue these select
committees
that's why nancy pelosi put liz cheney
on here because she's seen this coming
she's not a [ __ ] idiot she knows
these morons are
playing political theater with this
select committee
they play political theater with the 911
style commission
that they that they didn't want to do
because that was bad news for them
well the reason why they're playing
politics with this is because they're
already setting up
a way to say it's all against us
this select committee that's all it is
it's all against
us no it's all democrats all
liberals them liberals like liz cheney
that that that liberal like let's change
it's all their fault it's all set up to
slam dunk us and get rid of us
as if liz cheney is some kind of secret
commie
socialist radical liberal or some [ __ ]
it's all theater all of it it's all
professional wrestling theater
just like eric swalwell said that's what
this is
because now nancy pelosi has to decide
are they just going to go with the
quorum
or is she going to nominate republicans
to this commission
which i think she should nominate i
personally think she should nominate
republicans to this commission
and she should nominate republicans who
did not
who did not oppose the people's will
and the state certifications will
of the electoral votes on january six
she should select republicans that did
that
she also she also should select
republicans
that voted to impeach the [ __ ]
that incited the insurrection
that's what she should do there's
there's there's plenty of republicans
there to do that
liz cheney's one of them adam kingsinger
is another one
there's at least a list of four more
those are the ones that we know
that's what she should do and that's
what kevin mccarthy is planning on her
doing
because she's gonna do that she's gonna
oh she's gonna appoint
republicans to be on the commission and
they're gonna be republicans
who voted not to oppose the people's
will
and the state certification and she's
going to select people
who voted to impeach trump for inciting
the riot
the insurrection the treasonous
insurrection
the sedition she's going to
to appoint those people kevin mccarthy
knows that
donald trump knows it mitch mcconnell
knows it the republican party knows it
fox news knows it and the reason why
they're doing this
is because they have to put on the
wrestling show they have to put on the
show
because the show is well all she did was
vote
anti-trumpers it's all against trump
trump to trump to trump trump trump
anti-trump
if if trump would go away if trump would
go away
not make statements not force these
boneheads
to put on their cheeto dust kneepads and
service him
no one would be talking about trump
other than in criminal courts
that's the only place trump would be
have any news is in criminal courts
no one would be talking about him on the
hill no one
not a [ __ ] soul but it's only because
they can't let their orange deed
their mussolini jesus they can't let him
go they just can't do it they can't do
it without him now
how in the world can you how in the
world can you perpetuate a fascist
movement without your fascist leader
how would you how would you even manage
to create a totalitarian state without
an authoritarian
how would you do that you can't
you can't and they went balls deep into
this
they have no policies none what's the
last [ __ ] policy you heard a
republican talk about
they're not they're not even anti-tax
anymore they don't talk about high taxes
or cutting taxes or or democrat spending
or whatever
they don't even talk about that [ __ ]
hell they brag they brag about the
coronavirus spending
about all the coronavirus spinning that
happens in their district all
now the checks the the the child tax
credit that's happening they want to
take credit for that
the infrastructure bill is going to be
passed they're going to work it through
it's going to happen it's eventually
going to happen they're going to be
oh we got you money for your bridges and
your roads
even though i didn't vote it and i voted
to oppose to even vote for it and even
to debate it i got you the money
it's all [ __ ] fake it's all theater
it's all [ __ ] the whole [ __ ] nine
yards
him putting jim jordan on the [ __ ]
select committee was not a serious thing
it wasn't because if it was he would put
serious [ __ ] people on the committee
not an unserious [ __ ] bag like jim
jordan
jim jordan's just trying to get on the
[ __ ] news just like rand paul with
anthony fauci it's just to get the
highlight
it's just to make sure on espn
that you get the chair shot to the back
you get that little clip in
and you get your name up there that's
what it's about to these [ __ ]
so i encourage not that nancy pelosi
watches my show but she could retweet it
to her
retweet this show to her right now
because i'm going to yell something at
her
nancy pelosi speaker pelosi if you're
listening
nominate nominate five republicans
who voted to certify the [ __ ] vote
who didn't
who didn't participate in the sedition
on january 6
and voted to impeach the [ __ ]
that incited
incited the insurrection find
five of those [ __ ] and put them
on the committee because that's what
they want
so do it because really honestly all the
stuff that they've wanted
all the stuff that they wanted to do it
hasn't worked it hasn't worked they
didn't they didn't get rid of obamacare
in the aca
they they couldn't manage to get out of
[ __ ] afghanistan like trump wanted
they they couldn't manage to build a
wall
they couldn't even conjure up enough
[ __ ] courage to
know that every week wasn't
infrastructure weak
they're [ __ ] worthless he's worthless
they're worthless and the reason why is
because they're not
serious it's all [ __ ] the whole lot
the whole caboodle
and they knew this going back when she
when she made the select committee and
gave kevin mccarthy
the the power to to
dominate five appointees to this
committee and the best part is the thing
that
that everyone's missing is nancy pelosi
knew that from the beginning
she knew that from the beginning she is
trump's
kryptonite and she knew what was gonna
happen
she knows this she she's played this
game
she come on folks again
i'm not always a nancy pelosi fan
but when she's the gqp gqp's kryptonite
i [ __ ] love me some speaker pelosi
can we just can we just get an amen
all right thanks for joining us today on
the tony michaels podcast
let's talk the tony michaels podcast
thanks for joining us
we're here every wednesday three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern
if we're not banned and if we're not
suspended we're here live on youtube
twitter and twitch so go check us out
now if you missed the podcast today
don't worry don't worry you can go
re-watch it on youtube
i'm also going to post it on all the
directories
all the podcast directories so apple
podcast spotify google it's all going to
be there you can all search it up there
and you can listen to it if you want to
listen to it
so thanks for joining me thanks for all
the support out there all the likes
and and all the shares and all the
comments that i get
i love when you guys comment thank you
and we'll see you next week's and surely
surely there's going to be some
more arrests by next week um
maybe maybe just maybe it'll be like
mad gats or something cuz you know [ __ ]
them
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them